l'industrie du voyage aérien était assez
chaotique au cours des dernières
semaines des derniers mois la demande en
voyage d'ailleurs est revenue à un
niveau pré pandémie mais les compagnies
aériennes peuvent pas suffire à la
demande on prévoit des difficultés entre
autres un manque de pilotes qualifié
alors Claudine il faut comprendre que de
moins en moins de pilotes qui sortent
des écoles de pilotage
puis Marc-André le processus pour
devenir un pilote bien c'est pas une
seule année c'est de nombreuses années
des milliers de dollars aussi du temps
de vol et pendant la pandémie c'est un
peu seul problème il y a eu plusieurs
pilotes qui ont été tout simplement
cloués au sol les écoles aussi ça a été
beaucoup plus compliqué donner les cours
pour les élèves alors on le voit vous
allez voir entre autres grâce à des
chiffres qui nous ont été fournis par
Transport Canada c'est vraiment frappant
la diminution de pilote certifié qui
sont sortis en fait avant la pandémie on
parlait d'environ 1000 pilotes un peu
plus de 1000 pilotes qui étaient
certifié qui obtenait leur permis de vol
et l'année dernière on est en bas de 300
donc 238 pilotes qui ont été certifiés
pour voler ici au Canada alors si
vraiment inquiétant pour l'industrie
puis on l'a vu pendant le temps des
fêtes en raison de pénurie de personnel
Sunwing dû à annuler au cours des deux
des deux semaines pendant le temps des
fêtes de nombre tout près de 70 vols il
y a eu plein près de 7000 plaintes aussi
qui ont été logés auprès de ce
transporteur parce que ceux qui
réussissent à obtenir ces pilotes
qualifiés mais ce sont souvent les
grandes compagnies alors Air Canada
ouest jet qui réussit à les attirer et
puis ça reste les autres transporteurs
et bien dans une situation où il manque
de pilote
unforce
alors les écoles et cette formule plus
de pilote Sunwing entre autres a fait
une demande pour faire venir des pilotes
de l'étranger ça a été refusé la rune
situation complexe qui nous démontre
qu'on risque d'avoir encore des
cassettes dans l'industrie du voyage au
cours des prochaines années merci
Claudine
connaissez la phrase quelquefois la
blague y a-t-il un pilote dans l'avion
bon je vais vous répondre un peu si vous
êtes assis dans l'avion il y a des très
fortes chances que oui un pilote si vous
êtes en attente d'un départ là c'est
autre chose parce que les compagnies
aériennes notamment manquent de pilote
qualifiés dans le moment ça survient au
moment où la reprise du voyage par avion
atteint des niveaux pré pandémies on va
en discuter tout de suite avec Jean
Lapointe pilote de ligne expert en
aviation civile sur la pointe j'ai pas
manqué mon cours quand j'ai dit une fois
assis il y a un pilote c'est
quand on est dans salle d'attente là
c'est moins sûr mais dites moi je vais
recommencer on peut l'appliquer à bien
des sphères vous savez les gens disent
mais où sont les gens qui étaient là
avant la pandémie je vais reposer la
même chose tout si pilote qui assurait
des liaisons par centaines et par
milliers au Canada où sont-ils
aujourd'hui ils ont tous quitté le
secteur
il y en a plusieurs qui ont été obligés
de prendre leur retraite parce qu'ils
sont arrivés à l'âge maximal qui était
de 65 ans à l'époque elle était de 60
ans mais justement par ce manque de
pilotes l'OACI avait permis aux sociétés
aérienne d'employer des pilotes plus
âgés maintenant pendant la pandémie
effectivement il y en a plusieurs qui
ont été mis à pied qui ont quitté le
domaine mais la pandémie n'explique pas
elle seule le manque de pilote important
que nous vivons actuellement il y a une
croissance vous l'avez dit la reprise
des vols passagers les vigoureuses n'ont
pas seulement vers le sud en cette
période hivernale ici au Québec mais sur
l'international les vols sont plein ce
matin à Montréal on avait un nouveau vol
qui arrive de New Delhi de Sao Paulo
alors il y a c'est très robuste au
niveau des passagers mais la pandémie a
fait aussi explosé le volcargo donc
ajouter les retraites et puis ajouter au
fait que la réglementation exige sur
plusieurs lenvoles maintenant plus de
pilotes dans les cabines de pilotage ce
qui amène aujourd'hui là le manque de
pilote j'ai plusieurs sociétés aériennes
bon est-ce que ça prend combien de temps
quand on part on dit là j'ai tiens j'ai
18 ans on a fait des cours de sciences
et tout ce qu'il faut je suis prêt à
aller à l'école de pilatage là et tout à
coup arrive on arrive en avril 2000 quoi
20 et là on est en pleine pandémie
est-ce que ça ça par exemple ça bloque
des étudiants qui se disent oh non
j'irai pas me lancer là-dedans
la période de pandémie ce n'était pas
nécessairement la période la plus rose
mais plusieurs pilotes dont je fais
partie continue d'encourager les jeunes
parce que les prévisions de
l'Organisation de l'aviation civile de
même que ceux qui construisent les
avions nous disent et c'est vérifiable
que à tous les 15 ans le nombre de
passagers qui est transporté sur la
planète voie doubler alors votre
question à savoir qu'est-ce que devrait
faire un jeune ou une jeune parce qu'on
est plus de plus en plus de jeunes
femmes qui qui appliquent soit qu'on
passe au Centre québécois de formation
aéronautique ou d'aviation qui est à
Chicoutimi si un programme offert par le
gouvernement mais si un jeune veut
passer par une école privée comme à
Saint-Hubert par exemple chez à
Richelieu ou autre chez carga bien il
faudra quand même dépenser une somme
importante de 90 dollars 90000 dollars
mais au bout de deux ans on aura les
papiers qui nous permettent les licences
pour appliquer un transporteur de 3e
niveau pour débuter sa carrière
là ça veut dire pilote de brosse pendant
un certain temps faut pousser l'avion
d'abord charger l'avion seul le pousser
un peu faire des allers-retours sur La
Tuque et avant d'atterrir un ATR 42 ou
etc etc il y a des années qui s'écoule
il y a des années ça prend deux ans de
formation en général mais maintenant
même
parler des génies électriques pour les
barrages électriques il y a de l'avenir
pour les jeunes pour ceux qui veulent se
lancer dans tous ces emplois là qui
peuvent être très très excitants merci
beaucoup monsieur la pointe d'avoir été
disponible
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI